a doctor burk here I'm going to cover a
point on the thyroid and the menstrual
cycle and pregnancy what is the
relationship between all three of those
if you ever talk to someone who has a
hypothyroid ask them what their periods
like and it's usually going to be either
pretty heavy
crampy excessive bleeding and the reason
why that is related is because that
heavy period is an estrogen dominant
situation and in high estrogen actually
inhibits or blocks the thyroid gland the
same exact thing with pregnancy as well
so when when a female gets pregnant the
estrogen goes up and the thyroid goes
down and even some women that are
borderline a hypothyroid they end up
with a pretty severe hypothyroid and
even women that are hypothyroid going in
the pregnancy have to take more than
medication because of this situation so
it's all about this estrogen situation
so now how do we kind of bring this back
here do we support the thyroid do you
take more medication I'm going to
recommend that you support more natural
type environmental things like like
avoid any type of soy in the diet make
sure that you're not having hidden soy
and in some of the diet foods
prepackaged foods and soy milk just stay
away from soy and the other thing is
that cruciferous is a very anti estrogen
ik food that you could take this is a
concentrate of all the cruciferous foods
that are will help clean up some of the
liver with estrogen and then the other
thing that I that you could do is take
ovary support for an overactive ovaries
if it is a cycle because this tends to
help the period be more regular less
intense less bleeding because it
supports the gland so those are the two
things that may help you that you might
want to consider but I just wanted to
show you the relationship between this
darn estrogen and hypothyroid and
especially if you're frustrated and
you're trying to figure it out you have
to kind of look more like
roll and there's other possibilities so
that's the tip of today and I'll see you
in the next video